everybody's got a question on their mind
he's like my shirt cuz I do its Hamilton
it's the first half guy J of 2014 so
let's start with some questions from all
of you amazing people all right first up
princess Shizu honey what games are you
looking forward to the most this year I
am super excited for titanfall I
actually I still have so many games that
I need to finish right now on Xbox one
so when I finish those I will be
prepared and ready for a new one Gouri
listen up I'm going to RTX this summer
RTX in Austin is so fun I absolutely
love the roosterteeth community I've
never met more amazing people ever by
far the coolest so I definitely hope
that I'll be able to make it to RTX this
year Quincy what is your favorite thing
that you got for Christmas actually I
just got my first electric toothbrush so
I'm pretty excited about it my mom's
like yeah you could return it if you
don't want him like no mom I want this
this is like a dream come true it's
something that I didn't even know that I
wanted and now my teeth feel so freaking
fresh crest is gonna be calling and
saying hi this question really got me
because I do I've done this so many
times if you drop it ice cube on the
floor do you pick it up or do you kick
it under the fridge no of course you
don't pick it up if you drop it ice cube
the first thing you do is kick it under
the fridge it intended me to smartphone
similar to the 3ds would you buy it I
definitely would
I love Nintendo I don't know how old
their smartphone would be because I
really love my iPhone but look I'm never
opposed to trying out some technology
you get crunk on New Year's Eve I I
didn't i sat in my computer edited
student Sasquatch videos
cleaned my room unpacked from my travels
from the holidays really really boring
and I really really enjoyed it cuz the
past couple of years got a little crazy
had a little more fun than I showed of
ended up in the hospital last year with
Jenna so let me tell you what it was a
really great chill New Year's and I
liked it
Josh wanted over be posting more gaming
videos and yes I will I haven't really
had time to record any and when I'm at
home it's so hard to do it home as in my
parents house now that I'm back here I'm
gonna be leading again so I don't even
know it's me more time in the day how
was my Christmas New Year's festivities
I just talked about my New Year's my
Christmas is great I spent it at home
with my family we had a great time
obviously we always have a great time
Jack wants to know if I was stranded on
a deserted island what three animals
what I bring to keep you company might
bring three pigs
I would probably breed them as much as I
could so that I could keep making more
pigs even though I don't really eat meat
anymore I would probably have to
slaughter them and eat them because I
would starve otherwise so I've got this
plan perfectly Mike Wilson it was
influenced me to start using my PC more
than my Mac don't get me wrong it
definitely still use my Mac a lot I use
my PC so much more now for video game
capture because it's so much easier to
do in a PC than a Mac so that's uh
that's really what has influenced me
also I love PC gaming sometimes more
than console so that's that's it that's
really all that is influenced it Nicole
Erica will you ever do a collab with
grace I love grace I would love to she
is like probably one of my favorite
people she's so funny and just the
things she says like where did you come
up with that like I don't even know what
the thought process was of you getting
to point B from point A I mean you went
from you basically went from point A all
the way to like points freaking I don't
know
another letter in the alphabet I'm super
excited of his grace actually started a
new YouTube channel
it's youtube.com slash its grace is no
longer gonna be able to be on Daily
Grace anymore so make sure you guys go
check out on your channel I'm so excited
I can't wait for all of her adventures
and not really sure what to expect
but that's the best part about grace you
never know what you're gonna get Andreea
Andres Andres what are my new year's
resolutions I first of all my first new
year's best solution was to not make a
resolution because why don't anybody
makes a resolution it's like oh I have
to do this have to do that and guess
what yeah don't ever stick to it so my
resolution was to not make one I'm doing
pretty good with it so far look I you
know in one of my blogs I said it's
gonna make it draw my life ya know I'm
still gonna do it you wanna know when I
don't know when it really honestly I
promise you here's my new year's
resolution I know make a draw my life
this year there it is that's my
resolution and I will do it so I have
360 some days depending upon when I post
this video to you make a draw my life if
you guys have any questions for any
future ask IG episodes make sure you
leave it in the comments below be sure
to check out my other youtube channels
because if I'm not posting here I'm
probably closer than one of those
youtube.com slash other ijustine
ijustine his iPhone I just didn't gaming
so make sure you guys check those out I
will see you in my next video and that's
it I hope you have a fabulous frickin
day thanks a lot